wait do you like me of course what's my
name
it's Jenny that's nice where Jen he was
my next guess
okay
I'm gonna sleep with you but your
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
you wanna grab breakfast
oh sorry I have to finish up some
homework
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so I'm you want to go to movies if you
like - oh sorry I have to take my buddy
to the airport
really want some time sorry I have an
appointment I never gave you a date
[Music]
hey this is really fun yeah we should
grab a drink sometime
Oh take my friends better we're actually
never set a time they just have a really
busy month yo what up man
glad you're still alive you chugged
enough fireball for the whole party and
then some yeah actually uh every name
was Madison yeah I don't know I think
I'm gonna hang back tonight actually I
got some homework to finish up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] Apple yeah yeah so you were
chatting about school make sure you
Madison
hey Eli Elliot from last night / this
morning yeah
it's John tonight okay can I talk to you
sure I can yeah
hey what's up I think what's going on
you never text me back oh yeah I told
you I was busy busy with him yeah is
that a problem no I just I we had a good
time yeah we did we had a lot of fun so
we should hang out again sure okay
but tonight I'm hanging out with John so
when do we get to hang out I don't know
I'll text you okay wait you don't have a
very good track record of doing that
okay Eliot can I be honest with you
please
last night I was drunk and I thought
you're really cute so I hooked up with
you but I mean like isn't that your
Thursday night routine with girls around
here that's not true no okay well I just
got out of a relationship really
recently and I don't want a boyfriend
and I guess we were just there
that was your rebound I had a really
really good time I just don't want like
somebody buying me brunch I'm sorry I'm
just this has never happened to me
before so really oh no
I hope you didn't think I was gonna fall
madly in love with you or something okay
well did you fall in love with me no
okay so I work at them yeah
friends friends cool you want to join
John and I for a drink I'm okay I'll be
around
my answer like how tell me this
respiratory about Iceland yeah so okay
so we're driving up the spill yeah
[Music]